>>> HAPPY WEEK FOUR, EVERYBODY.
WELCOME TO "THE SQUAD RIDE" LIVE
IN THE BLEACHER REPORT APP
PRESENTED BY DRAFT KINGS.
BRADY IS RETURNING TO FOXBOROUGH
TONIGHT.
WE'LL TALK ALL THINGS PATS, BUCS
TODAY.
YOU KNOW ME AND GREG HAS
SOMETHING SPECIAL TO GIVE
TY LAW.
TY, YOU PLAYED WITH BRADY AND
BELICHICK FOR A LONG TIME.
GIVE US THE PLUG.
I DON'T WANT TO WASTE TIME.
WHO IS WINNING THIS GAME
TONIGHT?
>> MAN, YOU KNOW WHAT?
AS A BETTING MAN, I'LL SAY BRADY
WAS GOING TO WIN, BUT WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT WHERE MY HEART WANT
TO GO, I'M GOING AND CHEERING ON
THE PATRIOTS, YOU KNOW WHAT I
MEAN?
FROM A TEAM STANDPOINT, THE BUCS
HAVE THE ADVANTAGE.
HEY, IT'S TIME TO GET AN UPSET
TODAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
BELICHICK MAY HAVE SOMETHING UP
HIS SLEEVE.
I'M CONCERNED WITH PERSONNEL
MATCHUP.
YOU'RE THE SPECIAL TEAMS AND GET
A TURNOVER.
GOOD THINGS CAN HAPPEN.
I'M GOING FOR THE PATRIOTS BUT
IF I WAS BETTING MONEY, I WOULD
BET ON THE BUCS.
>> SMART MAN.
DON'T BET WITH YOUR HEART.
ABSOLUTELY.
WE'RE DOING THINGS DIFFERENT.
EVERY WEEK WE ASK FOR ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN SCORERS.
BRADY RETURNING TO FOXBOROUGH
AND TY LAW.
BRADY IS 68 YARDS AWAY FROM
BREAKING THE PASSING RECORD AND
WE WANT TO KNOW FROM YOU, THE
SQUAD, WHO IS THE LOCK TO CATCH
THE RECORD-BREAKING PASS?
ON FRIDAY WE ASKED YOU ON SOCIAL
TO DROP YOUR PICKS.
THESE ARE THE MOST POPULAR PICKS
YOU SENT US.
NO SURPRISE.
GODWIN AND EVANS WITH AB COMING
IN BEHIND THEM.
REMEMBER, NO GRONK IN THIS GAME.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT DARK HORSE
TIGHT END CANDIDATES AND O.J.
HOWARD, THEY GOT THE TWO-HEADED
BACKFIELD THAT'S REALLY BEEN ONE
GUY THIS YEAR.
RONALD JONES AND THE DOG HOUSE A
BIT AND THE UNDER DOG IN TYLER
JOHNSON HERE.
SO PRETTY BIG BOARD.
WE'RE EXCITED TO LOOK AT IT
TODAY AND WE'RE EXCITED TO HEAR
FROM YOU.
GREG, TELL THE PEOPLE WHAT WE'RE
GIVING AWAY TODAY.
>> TY, YOU'LL SEE HOW WE DO
THINGS AROUND HERE.
WE GIVE AWAY HOODIES.
WE GIVE AWAY JERSEYS AND JUST
BECAUSE I'M FEELING SPECIAL,
JUST BECAUSE I'M FEELING SPECIAL
AND JUST BECAUSE YOU HERE, BRO,
JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE HERE, I'M
GIVING AWAY AN iPHONE 13 TODAY.
STAY LOCKED IN RIGHT HERE.
I'M GIVING AWAY THE iPHONE 13.
THE JERSEY WILL GO TO THE
WINNING LOCK LEGEND AND THE
iPHONE WILL GO TOM COMMENTER AT
THE END OF THE SHOW.
STAY AROUND.
STICK AROUND.
CHILL OUT WITH ME, CONNER, TY
AND POTENTIALLY W L
LY WIN TH.
WHAT I NEED YOU TO DO NOW IS GET
IN THE COMMENTS AND IF YOU WANT
A JERSEY, IF YOU WANT A HOODIE
AND IF YOU WANT THIS iPHONE, I
NEED GIFS, EMOJIS.
JUST FOR FUN, TY, JUST FOR FUN,
I'M GOING TO SHOW Y'ALL HOW I DO
IT.
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE A HOODIE
NOW.
TY, CONNER, THIS RIGHT HERE TY
IS THE HANDY DANDY IPAD.
THIS IS HOW EVERYBODY WINS THEIR
HOD
HOODIES.
THIS IS HOW EVERYBODY WINS THEIR
JERSEYS.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
I'M NOT COMMENTS AND GOAT
GARDEN, GOAT GARDEN HAS A GIF.
IT SAYS GREG SPRINKLES.
CONNER, YOU KNOW HOW I FEEL WHEN
THEY TALK TO ME.
>> I KNOW.
>> THEY TALK TO ME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> GOAT GARDEN.
>> SPEAKING OF FAVORITES --
>> WE HAVE FOUR LEGENDARY PICKS
TO SHOW YOU.
THE LAST ONE STANDING AT THE
SQUAD RIDE LEADER.
THEY HAVE THE JERSEY AND TITLE
BUT BEFORE WE GET INTO THAT
LET'S LOOK AT ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN
VIDEOS THAT DIDN'T MAKE THE
SHOW.
WE HAVE TO SHOW YOU GUYS SO HERE
THEY ARE.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO GET A
TOUCHDOWN THIS WEEKEND?
>> ANY TIME T.D. SCORES.
>> HERE IT IS.
>> IF I LOSE, TYLER LOCKET.
>> TYLER LOCKET.
ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN SCORE.
HOLLYWOOD BROWN, LOCK IT IN.
>> WOO HOO, LET'S GO!
>> THE CREATIVITY IS LOOKING
GREAT.
KEEP MORE VIDEOS COMING.
I MIGHT HAVE TO PUT A SAFETY
WARNING ON THE NEXT TIME WE ASK
FOR THESE.
GETTING A LITTLE NUTS.
FIRST PITCH OF THE WEEK FROM
HOOD RICH NATHAN.
THAT'S RIGHT.
YOU HEARD IT HERE.
TELL US WHO IS CATCHING THAT
RECORD BREAKER TODAY.
ALL RIGHT.
HOOD RICH NATHAN GOING WITH AB.
THAT PLUS MONEY.
THAT PLUS 450 LOOKING GOOD AND
HE'S GOT A PRETTY GOOD CONTENDER
HERE, A FAMILIAR FACE IN
RILEY SORBO.
I SEE CHICKENS COMING UP.
>> ALL RIGHT.
YOU GUYS KNOW THE MISSION.
TOM BRADY, HE'S GOING TO T
THE RECORD PASS TO WHICH PLAYER
TODAY WE'VE GOT FOURNETTE,
LEONARD FOURNETTE WITH THE RUN
AWAY.
MIKE EVANS, DIDN'T HAVE A CHANCE
ALL OF THEM LOVE THOSE TWO.
>> OH MY GOODNESS.
ALL RIGHT.
YOU SEEN THE FIRST TWO PITCHES.
TELL THE PEOPLE WHAT WE NEED
RIGHT NOW.
>> WHAT I NEED EVERYBODY TO DO
IS GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL
ME WHO WE SHOULD RIDE WITH.
SHOULD WE RIDE WITH THE OBSTACLE
LEGEND IN ANTONIO BROWN OR GO TO
THE FARM AND RIDE WITH THE
CHICKEN LEGEND IN LEONARD
FOURNETTE.
TY, WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING?
ARE YOU GOING A.B. OR LEONARD
FOURNETTE ON THE FARM?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M GOING TO GO LEONARD
FOURNETTE ON THE FARM BECAUSE
TOM LIKES THE DUMP OFF.
HE LIKES THE TIGHT ENDS AND
RUNNING BACKS.
AND HE'S NOT GOING TO FORCE IT
JUST TO BREAK THE RECORD OR TRY
TO GO DOWN FIELD TO A.B. OR
GODWIN OR SOMEONE LIKE THAT.
I THINK ON THAT PARTICULAR PLAY
WHEN HE BREAKS THE RECORD,
LEONARD FOURNETTE.
DROP DOWN SCREEN STUFF LIKE
THAT.
>> YEAH, I'M ROLLING WITH TY.
I WOULD GO FOURNETTE, AS WELL.
I LIKE THE CHICKEN CONCEPT.
I'M TERRIFIED OF CHICKENS,
ROOSTERS BUT I LIKE THE VIDEO.
FOURNETTE IS THE GUY.
WE'VE SEEN VERY LITTLE OF RONALD
JONES SINCE THE OPENING KICKOFF
WEEK ONE FUMBLE.
FOURNETTE WILL BE ON THE FIELD A
LOT.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT I THINK,
GREG.
WHAT DO THE PEOPLE THINK?
THEY GET TO DECIDE THIS IN THE
END.
>> CONNER, BEFORE I HOP INTO THE
COMMENTS LET ME GIVE MY TAKE
HERE.
A FOR EFFORT FOR ANTONIO BROWN,
THE OBSTACLE LEGEND.
THAT WAS GOOD EFFORT.
BUT THE CHICKEN LEGEND IN
RILEY SORBO WON ME OVER.
TY TALKS ABOUT HOW TOM LIKES TO
DUMP THE BALL DOWN AND LEONARD
FOURNETTE IS THERE.
LET ME HOP INTO THESE COMMENTS.
NOT ABOUT WHAT I THINK AND Y'ALL
THINK, IT'S ABOUT WHAT THE
PEOPLE ARE THINKING AND I'M
SEEING A LOT OF A.B.
I'LL BE HONEST.
I'M SEEING A LOT OF A.B.,
CONNER.
I GOT MAD DODGER IN THE COMMENTS
TALKING ABOUT A.B.
I GOT MIKE RITTER, MIKE RITTER
IS IN THE COMMENTS.
HE'S SHOUTING RILEY SORBO IN THE
CHICKEN LEGEND.
BOTH OF PEOPLE SAY WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
I GOT LEWIS ROCKING WITH ABA.
I'LL DO IT LIKE THIS CONNER AND
TY.
THE NEXT ONE I LAND ON IS WHO I.
AND BAM.
I GOT MAXIELL REXEL SAYING
LEONARD FOURNETTE AND THE
CHICKEN LEGEND.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
THEREFORE, CONNER, TY, THE
CHICKEN LEGEND IN LEONARD
FOURNETTE IS MOVING ONTO THE
NEXT ROUND.
>> CHICKEN LEGEND.
>> SHOUTOUT TO RILEY.
LEONARD FOURNETTE.
WE STILL HAVE TWO CHALLENGERS
REMAINING ONTO THE NEXT ROUND.
PITCH FROM ANOTHER FAMILIAR FACE
W. TRAM MEL.
LET'S SEE WHO YOU GOT.
>> WHO ARE YOU RIDING WITH TO
GET THAT RECORD PASS?
GODWIN, LOCK IT IN.
>> THE FAV RIORITE ON THE BOARD
THERE.
STILL PLUS MONEY.
IT'S NOT A CHALKY PICK.
I LIKE IT.
GREG, WHAT DO WE NEED FROM THE
PEOPLE RIGHT NOW?
>> WHAT I NEED YOU GUYS TO DO IS
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL US
WHO WE SHOULD RIDE WITH.
IF WE RIDING WITH THE BOAT
LEGEND IN CHRIS GODWIN OR
KEEPING IT ON THE FARM.
RILEY ROCKING WITH FORNURNETTE.
DID THE BOAT LEGEND WIN YOU OVER
OR ARE YOU STILL BEING LOYAL TO
THE FARM LAND AND THE CHICKEN?
>> I'M STILL BEING LOYAL TO THE
FARM LAND.
I MEAN, THE BOAT, IT WAS COOL.
BO
BOAT LEGEND WAS COOL AND I KNOW
TOM BRADY.
HE'S GOING TO DUMP IT OFF TO
KEEP THE CHANGE GOING AND LIVE
TO PLAY ANOTHER DAY.
ODDS ARE HE WILL GO TO LEONARD
FOURNETTE AND STICK WITH THAT.
I DON'T GIVE A DAMN WHAT Y'ALL
SHOW.
I'M GOING WITH LEONARD FOUR
E
FOURNETTE.
>> TY IS ROCKING WITH FOURNETTE
UNTIL THE END.
I'LL CITY WITH HIM HERE BECAUSE
I DON'T PICK FAVORITES AND
GODWIN WAS THE GUY AT THE TOP.
ALL RIGHT.
GREG, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
PLEASE DO.
>> HEY, NOW IF GRONK WAS
PLAYING.
>> UT OH.
>> AND NOW HE MIGHT DO THAT
INTENTIONALLY JUST SO -- NOW, IT
WILL BE A TOTALLY DIFFERENT
STORY GRONK WAS PLAYING.
I DON'T THINK THERE WILL BE MUCH
EMPHASIS EVEN THOUGH BROWN WAS
HERE FOR A CUP OF COFFEE BUT
HEY, GRONK IS HANDS DOWN WOULD
HAVE MADE IT A POINT TO BREAK
THE RECORD.
>> THAT'S A MOMENT THEY WANT
TOGETHER, RIGHT?
>> EXACTLY.
EXACTLY.
>> THOSE GUYS, THEY DO
EVERYTHING TOGETHER.
SO IT WOULDN'T SHOCK THEM AT
THAT RECORD.
GREG, WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS?
>> I MEAN, THE BOAT LEGEND, I'LL
JUST SAY THIS PICK FLOATS MY
BOAT.
I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT.
YOU GUYS SEE WHAT I DID THERE.
BUT THIS CHRIS GODWIN LIKES TO
FIND THEM DEEP AND DOWN THE
FIELD, MAYBE IT MAY HAPPEN IN
ONE PASS.
WHO KNOWS.
BUT IT'S NOT ABOUT WHAT I THINK.
WE'VE BEEN THROUGH THIS BEFORE.
I'LL HOP BACK TO THIS HANDY
DANDY IPAD AND SEE WHO THE
PEOPLE THINKS IS V MOMOVING ON
THE NEXT ROUND.
I GOT J.T. SAYS GODWIN.
SHUTOUTS.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE.
I GOT MELLOW FOR ROOKIE OF THE
YEAR.
MELLOW FOR ROOKIE OF THE YEAR IS
AGREEING WITH YOU, TY.
HE SAYS IF ONLY GRONK WAS THERE.
WE ALL KNOW GRONK WOULD BE
GETTING THIS PASS IF HE WAS
PLAYING TOGETHER.
GRONK WOULD PROBABLY NOT EVEN BE
IN THE -- IT PROBABLY WOULD NOT
EVEN BE IN THE PLUS.
IT WOULD BE LIKE NEGATIVE, MINUS
110 AROUND THERE.
BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW THAT GRONK
PROBABLY WILL BE GETTING THAT
PASS IF HE WAS IN THE GAME.
I'LL GIVE AWAY ONE MORE HOODIE
AND WE'LL MOVE ON.
HERE WE GO.
I GOT DJE 779 -- DJE 779 SAYS
GODWIN, THERE FOREVER THE BOAT
LEGEND IS MOVING ONTO THE NEXT
ROUND.
SHOUTOUT TO W TRAMMEL.
>> CHRIS GOD WWIN THE FAVORITE
THE BOARD BUT WE HAVE ONE MORE
ROUND.
ALL RIGHT?
SOMEBODY HAS TO TAKE HOME THIS
JERSEY.
SOMEONE HAS TO TAKE HOME THE
SQUAD RIDE LEADER TITLE.
WINNER TAKES ALL.
FINAL ROUND.
WHOEVER WINS THE NEXT ONE GETS A
BOOST.
EVERYBODY SHOULD JUMP ON THAT
LET'S DO IT.
NEXT ONE UP IS FROM JESSIE
BURNSTONE.
LET'S SEE THE PICK HERE.
>> THE LOMONSTER SESSION, WHAT
WE NEED TO DECIDE THE WEEK FOUR
WINNER?
>> I NEED YOU TO HOP INTO THE
COMMENTS AND LET US KNOW WHO IS
GOING TO WIN THIS.
ARE YOU GUYS ROCKING WITH CHRIS
GODWIN?
PLUS 330.
BOAT LEGEND LOCKNESS LEGEND.
IT'S GETTING DOWN TO THE NITTY
GRITTY AND TY, YOU ALREADY KNOW
WHAT I'M GOING TO DO.
I'M CALLING ON YOU.
YOU BATTING LEAD OFF.
WHO ARE YOU ROCKING WITH?
CHRIS GODWIN OR MIKE EVANS TO
CATCH THIS PASS FROM TOM BRADY?
>> NO, IF I HAD TO CHOOSE TWO
RECEIVERS -- ONE OF THOSE TWO
RECEIVERS, I WOULD SAY MIKE
EVANS BECAUSE HE'S THE DOWN
FIELD GUY.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
THAT COULD BE ONE BALL.
ONE BALL HE CAN BE DONE.
I'LL SAY GODWIN.
IF IT'S ONE PASS BECAUSE HE DOES
SO MANY THINGS DOWN THE FIELD
AND MIKE EVANS, HE CAN PUT AN
END TO ALL OF IT IN ONE PLAY.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> HOW MANY YARDS WE NEED?
>> 68.
THIS COULD BE IN THE FIRST
QUARTER.
>> YEAH, THIS IS DEFINITELY
GOING TO BE IN THE FIRST
QUARTER.
FIRST QUARTER.
IF I GOT TO GO WITH GODWIN ON
THAT ONE.
TOM LOOKS FOR HIM MORE.
>> IT'S TOUGH.
IT'S A TOTAL TOSSUP.
I'LL GO THE OTHER WAY WITH MIKE
EVANS COMING OFF A TEN TARGET
WEEK.
THAT'S A SEASON HIGH FOR HIM.
YOU KNOW BRADY SPREADING AROUND
THE BALL LIKE NOBODY ELSE.
COULD BE GODWIN OR FOURNETTE OFF
THE FARM.
WE'RE NOT GOING WITH THAT HERE.
GREG, WHAT'S YOUR FINAL TAKE OF
WHAT THE PEOPLE THINK?
>> LET ME HOP INTO THIS HANDY
DANDY GUY.
THE COMMENTS ARE JUMPING.
I GOT SEAN PAUL.
I WOULD SHOW YOU BUT THE
COMMENTS KEEP JUMPING.
ROCKING WITH THE MIKE EVANS GIFF
BOBBING AND WEAVING IN THE GIPH.
SHOUT OUT.
EVERYONE I MENTIONED ARE WALKING
A
AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
HERE WE GO.
>> LET'S DO IT.
BAM, MIKE EVANS.
MIKE EVANS FOR SURE.
SO THEREFORE, TY, THEREFORE,
CONNER, WE ARE RIDING WITH MIKE
EVANS.
SHOUTOUT TO JESSIE BURNSTONE AND
THE LOCH NESS LEGEND.
LET ME SHOW Y'ALL WHO ONLY WE
CAN DO HERE ON "THE SQUAD RIDE."
YOU GUYS SEE WHERE IT SAYS MIKE
EVANS PLUS 400?
POOF.
THERE IS THE MAGIC THERE, TY.
THERE IS THE MAGIC RIGHT THERE.
>> OH, OKAY!
>> WE JUST BOOSTED IT.
WE JUST BOOSTED IT FROM 400 PLUS
400 TO PLUS 500.
THANKS TO OUR FRIENDS AT DRAFT
KINGS.
CHECK BR BETTING SOCIAL SOCIAL
LATE TO THE ODDS BOOST.
SEND US YOUR SCREEN SHOTS OF
YOUR BETS AND SEND US VIDEOS OF
YOUR CELEBRATIONS.
WE WANT WINNERS ONLY, PLEASE.
>> WE'RE NOT DONE YET.
WE HAVE LOCKS TO GIVE AWAY,
HOODIES TO GIVE AWAY, AN iPHONE
TO GIVE AWAY.
YOU KNOW THE DEAL BY NOW.
HANG OUT IN THE BETTING
COMMUNITY APP, WE ASK YOU EVERY
WEEK SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
THIS WEEK IS WHAT TOM BRADY POP
IS A LOCK.
LET'S LOOK AT THE POPULAR BRADY
PROPS ON THE BOARD.
THIS IS WHAT YOU SEE EVERY WEEK.
PASSING YARD TOTAL, COMPLEXES MY
PERSONAL FAVORITE.
GET THE OLD MAN'S LEGS MOVING
AND BRADY RUSHING TOUCHDOWN AT
PLUS 380 BUT LET'S TAKE A LOOK
AT THE SPECIAL PROPS OF BRADY
COMING BACK TO FOXBOROUGH.
THE SPECIAL PROPS OF THE GAME.
DRAFT KINGS OFFERING A 25%
PROFIT BOOST TONIGHT.
YOU CAN BET UP TO THREE AND TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE BOOST.
ALL KINDS OF BIG TIME ONES
BASICALLY CAREER HIGHS.
NUMBER OF COMPLETED PASSES FOR
HIM TO GET OVER THAT 67.5
PASSING YARD MARK.
WE ASKED FOR YOUR FAVORITES AND
PICKED TWO COMMENTS TO LOOK AT.
GREG, LET THEM KNOW WHAT'S UP.
>> YES, SIR.
I GOT YOU, CONNERME.
I NEED EVERYBODY TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND ELOQUENTTELL US WH
THESE COMMENTS YOU LIKE BETTER.
I'M GIVING A HOODIE TO WHATEVER
YOU CHOOSE.
LET'S TAKE A WILOOK AT THE
COMMENTS.
THERE IT IS.
BRADY IS GOING TO THROW A
TOUCHDOWN PASS IN EACH HALF AND
HE'S CALLING IT A LOCK.
>> EASY MONEY.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK, TODD?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> IT WOULD HAVE BEEN MORE
INTERESTING IF YOU SAID A
TOUCHDOWN IN EACH QUARTER.
>> YES.
>> THAT'S NOT HARD.
HELL, I CAN THROW A TOUCHDOWN
EACH HALF.
WE CAN GO THROUGH THAT.
THAT'S NOTHING.
THAT'S ABSOLUTE EASY.
>> OH, MAN, ESPECIALLY MIKE
EVANS AND CHRIS GODWIN, YOU'D
HAVE A GOOD CHANCE, TY.
>> REAL GOOD CHANCE.
>> I AGREE THAT'S A LOCK BUT
THAT'S NOT TOO MUCH OF A
CHALLENGE FOR SOMEONE --
>> GREG, WHAT ELSE?
>> MY BOY TY, MY BOY TY SAYS
THAT'S A LOT.
BUT LET'S MOVE ONTO THE NEXT
ONE.
LET'S MOVE ONTO THE NEXT ONE
FROM BALD EAGLE 1248, BALD EAGLE
1248 SAYS BRADY BREAKS THE
RECORD ON HIS FIRST DRIVE.
OH, THIS IS INTERESTING.
WE JUST TALKED ABOUT THIS.
TY, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
DO YOU THINK THIS IS A GOOD
TAKE?
>> I THINK THAT'S A DAMN GOOD
TAKE AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
TO GET IT OUT OF THE WAY, SO
MUCH CELEBRATION.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY GOT
PLANNED BUT YOU KNOW IT'S GOING
TO BE SOME 15, 20-MINUTE
CELEBRATION WITH TOM BRADY.
YOU KNOW THEY'RE GOING TO STOP
THE GAME.
LET GET IT OUT OF THE WAY.
THEY WILL STOP THE GAME AND
CELEBRATE.
DO ALL THAT.
THE FIRST DRIVE, YOU KNOW, COULD
BE IT.
I LIKE THAT.
YOU KNOW, BECAUSE IF HE'S GOING
TO COME OUT SWINGING KNOWING TOM
AND HIS COACH AND BRUCE ARIANS,
THEY WANT TO MAKE A POINT RIGHT
AWAY.
LET'S GET THIS RECORD AND LET'S
GO ON AND FINISH THE GAME AND
PLAY FOOTBALL.
I AGREE THAT HE GETS IT IN THE
FIRST DRIVE.
>> YEAH, GET THE DISTRACTION OUT
OF THE WAY.
A LOT OF YARDS BUT NOT A LOT OF
YARDS FOR THIS OFFENSE.
THEY WILL HAVE THEIR FOOT ON THE
GAS TO MAKE IT ABOUT THE
FOOTBALL AFTER THIS IS OVER.
SO GREG, WHAT DO THE PEOPLE
THINK OF THESE?
>> HEY, IT'S SO FUNNY.
I'M LOOKING AT THE COMMENTS AS
THEY COME IN.
I GOT STEELERS KB.
HE GOT AN EAGLE FLYING.
THE GUY NAME WAS BALD EAGLE.
HE HAS A BALD EAGLE FLYING AND
GIPH.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I GOT AMOU 812, AMOU 812.
THE SO THEY ARE LOVING MY GUY
BALD EAGLE'S TAKE OF THE FIRST
DRIVE, BRADY BREAKING THE
RECORD.
I GOT ONE MORE.
I GOT ONE MORE FOR YOU CONNER.
FIRST PLAY HE'S GOING TO BREAK
THE RECORD.
FIRST PLAY.
ONE BIG PLAY TO MIKE EVANS --
>> KNOCK IT OUT.
>> ON THE SIDELINES.
>> JUST FOR ADVICE, I'VE GEMMING
TH
-- GIVING THEM A HOODIE.
SA
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE AND ALSO, BALD EAGLE IS
WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE FOR
HIS TAKE BECAUSE EVERYBODY SEEMS
TO LIKE TOM BRADY BREAKING THE
RECORD IN THE FIRST DRIVE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S LOOK AT BOLD BETS.
WE TALKED ABOUT ALL THE THINGS
BRADY IS GOING TO DO AND WE HAVE
NOT TALKED ABOUT IF THE PATRIOTS
CAN STOP THEM AND T,Y
Y, YOU'RE
LEGEND.
PLAYED WITH BRADY AND BELICHICK.
YOU WON THREE SUPER BOWLS.
YOU KNOW THEM AS WELL AS ANYBODY
THAT'S PLAYED IN THE NFL.
DO YOU THINK BILL KNOWS WHAT IT
TAKES?
DE
HE DEFINITELY KNOWS BUT HAS WHAT
IT TAKES TO SHUT DOWN BRADY AND
THE BUCS OFFENSE TONIGHT.
>> YES.
I REALLY BELIEVE THAT HE HAS
SOMETHING UP HIS SLEEVE BUT I GO
BACK TOWARDS, I'VE ALWAYS SAID
IT'S ABOUT THE PERSONNEL.
COACH BELICHICK CAN'T GO OUT
THERE AND TACKLE NOBODY AND
CAN'T GO OUT THERE AND COVER
NOBODY.
HE CAN PUT THE RIGHT PIECES AND
THE RIGHT GUYS ON THE FIELD TO
MAKE IT HAPPEN.
DO THEY HAVE THE RIGHT GUYS IN
THE LOCKER ROOM?
I DON'T KNOW.
THAT'S YET TO BE SEEN.
NOW, IF YOU -- AND IF YOU TOOK
BILL BELICHICK AND THE DEFENSE I
PLAYED ON AND WITH MYSELF, WILLY
MCELD
MCGUINESS, BRIT WOULD BE A
DIFFERENT TYPE OF SITUATION.
>> SEEMS LIKE THE PATRIOTS
ALWAYS HAVE THE NUMBER ONE
CORNER, WHETHER IT WAS YOU.
THEY HAD REVIS AND GILMORE.
I LIKE JC JACKSON A LOT.
THAT'S A LOT TO ASK FOR ONE GUY
AGAINST BRADY.
WE WANT TO KNOW, IS HE GOING TO
THROW AN INTERCEPTION TONIGHT?
THE CURRENT LINE FOR HIM TO
THROW AN INTERCEPTION IS OVER
UNDER SET AT A HALF.
BASICALLY IS HE GOING TO THROW
ONE?
IS HE GOING TO NOT?
THAT'S ALL WE WANT TO KNOW.
YOU PICKED THE GUY OFF.
NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE CAN SAY
THAT, REALLY.
THERE IS NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT CAN SAY THAT.
DO YOU THINK HE'LL THROW AN
INTERCEPTION IN HIS RETURN TO
FOXBOROUGH TONIGHT?
>> NO, I DON'T -- YOU KNOW WHAT?
DAMMIT, YES.
>> THERE WE GO.
BOLD MONEY.
>> BECAUSE THE DEFENSE GOT TO
STEP UP.
YOU KNOW WHAT I DEFENSIVE GUY, O
IN WITH THE MENTALITY YOU GOING
TO MAKE A PLAY, YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO MAKE ONE.
IF I'M THERE, HE'LL THROW AN
INTERCEPTION.
I HOPE EVERYONE IN THERE FEELS
THE SAME WAY THAT I WOULD FEEL
AS A DEFENSIVE BACK.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THAT AS A
CHALLENGE.
SO I KNOW McCOURTY WILL BE
READY.
HE KNOWS TOM WELL.
MAYBE HE CAN COME UP WITH A
PLAY.
LIKE I SAID, STEPHON GILMORE,
HE'S NOT THERE BUT JACKSON, HEY,
YOU KNOW, HE'S GOING TO GET
TRIED.
THAT'S THE THING.
BRADY IS GOING TO TRY YOU.
CAN YOU MAKE A COMMITMENT?
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
HE PROBABLY WOULDN'T TRY BECAUSE
HE TRIED ME AND PAID FOR IT.
HE MIGHT NOT TREY STEPHON
GILMORE.
IT'S UP TO YOU TO COME UP THERE
AND MAKE A PLAY.
>> YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
I KNOW JACKSON WAS QUESTIONABLE
BUT IF HE'S ON THE FIELD, I'M
WITH YOU ALL THE WAY.
GREG, WHAT DO THE COMMENTS THINK
SO FAR?
>> I WAS IN THE COMMENTS,
ACTUALLY.
I WAS IN THE COMMENTS.
THEY'RE GOING ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
I'LL GIVE OUT ONE HOODIE.
I'LL SAY -- I SEE TANIKA PLAN
SAYS PATRIOTS NEED TY LAW TO
STEP IN, STOP BRADY FROM COOKING
THEM.
TY, THEY WANT YOU BACK OUT THERE
ON THE FIELD.
WANTS YOU BACK OUT THERE ON THE
FIELD.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
>> OH, MAN.
ALL RIGHT.
>> YOU KNOW THE ODDS OF THAT?
IF I WAS OUT THERE ON THE FIELD,
THE ODDS HE WOULD DEFINITELY
SCORE A TOUCHDOWN BECAUSE I
CAN'T RUN NO MORE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I APPRECIATE IT.
YOU DON'T WANT ME OUT THERE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE ALMOST OUT OF TIME SO
LET'S GET THE BOLDEST BETS AND
THANK TY FOR JOINING US.
THESE ARE NOT LOCKS.
THESE ARE FUN, LONG SHOTS.
I FINALLY GOT ONE LAST WEEK.
MIKE WILLIAMS CALLED HIS TWO
TOUCHDOWNS.
FEELING GOOD.
I KNOW TREY SHERMAN SCORED.
WE'RE HOT NOW.
I WON'T LIE.
WE'RE KIND OF HOT.
ALL RIGHT.
BOLDEST BETS HERE, GREG.
LET'S GET INTO IT.
BOLDEST BETS.
>> YEAH.
BOLDEST BET.
LET ME TALK TO HIM, CONNER.
I GOT YOU.
EVERYBODY GET IN THE COMMENTS
AND TELL ME WHETHER YOU'RE
RIDING WITH ME OR RIDING WITH
CONNER, MY GUY HIT ON THE TWO
TOUCHDOWNS.
I'LL LET YOU FLAUNT WHATEVER HE
DID.
HE DID HIT LAST WEEK.
YOU HIT LAST WEEK BUT WHAT DO
YOU GOT THIS WEEK FOR THE
PEOPLE?
>> IF IT'S NOT BROKEN, DON'T TRY
TO FIX IT.
MIKE WILLIAMS, TWO TOUCHDOWNS,
LET'S GO EASIER.
TYREEK HILL, THIS IS A GUY HE
CATCHES HIM IN BUMPS AND NOT
DONE THAT THROUGH THREE WEEKS
THIS YEAR AGAINST THE EAGLE'S
SECON
SECONDARY.
BIG-TIME WEEK.
TWO TOUCHDOWNS FOR HIM.
LET'S ROLL WITH IT.
GREG, WHAT DO YOU GOT?
>> I LIKE THAT.
I LIKE THAT.
I WANT TO GO TO CHICAGO.
I GOT THE LIONS FACING THE
BEARS.
AND THE LIONS, MAN, THEY HAVE
BEEN GETTING HIT ON THEIR CHIN
THIS YEAR, TY.
THEY WENT TO -- MATHEY PLAYED S
FRANCISCO.
SAN FRANCISCO WAS BEATING THEM
AND THEY CAME BACK AND THEN THEY
WENT TO PLAY THE PACKERS.
THAT GAME WAS HARD FOUGHT IN THE
FIRST HALF AND THE BACKERS TOOK
CARE OF THEM IN THE SECOND HALF.
LAST WEEK AGAINST THE RAVINS, IT
WAS CLOSE UNTIL THE END.
MY BOY TUCKER HIT -- IT WAS A
LONG FIELD GOAL.
HE'S ON MI
Y FANTASY TEAM.
66 YARDS.
TH ARE DUE FOR A WIN AND UNDER
DOGS.
THEY'RE UNDER DOGS.
THEY'RE DUE FOR A WIN.
I'LL GO WIN MARGIN HERE.
I'LL GO WIN MARGIN HERE, CONNER.
THEY WILL WIN ONE TO SIX POINTS.
SEE A CLOSE ONE BUT PULLING AWAY
WITH THE VICTORY.
SO THE LIONS BY ONE OF SIX
POINTS TODAY.
>> TY, WHAT ARE YOU ROLLING
WITH?
TWO TOUCHDOWNS OR THE LIONS
UPSET OVER CHICAGO?
>> I -- THE LIONS ARE DUE FOR A
WIN.
I GOT TO SAY BECAUSE THEY FIGHT.
THEY FIGHT HARD.
YOU GOT TO GIVE IT TO THEM.
I LIKE THE LIONS WITH THE UPSET
AND THEN JUSTIN FIELDS AS MUCH
AS I LIKE HIM, HE'S STILL A
YOUNG QUARTERBACK AND THEY'RE
NOT PLAYING GREAT FOOTBALL.
THEY HAVE A GREAT DEFENSE BUT
NOT PLAYING GREAT FOOTBALL AS A
TEAM.
I LIKE THE LIONS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
GREG, I KNOW YOU GOT THIS iPHONE
TO GIVE AWAY BEFORE WE GET OUT
OF HERE.
LET'S GET TO IT.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> LET'S GET STRAIGHT TO IT.
I'M NOT COMMENTS, MAN.
I'M
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I SEE BIG MIKE 13 SAYS GREG, I'M
RIDING WITH YOU, MY MAN.
THAT NEW iPHONE FOR BETTING WITH
BETTER SERVICE, GUESS WHAT BIG
MIKE 13?
CHRISTMAS HAS JUST CAME EARLY.
I HOPE -- WE WERE GOING TO SEND
YOU THE iPHONE AND I HOPE YOUR
SERVICE GETS BETTER TO TAP IN
WITH US EVERY WEEK HERE ON "THE
SQUAD RIDE SHOW" EVERY SUNDAY.
SHOUTOUT TO BIG MIKE 13.
HE'S WALKING AWAY WITH THE
iPHONE 13.
>> SHUTOUT TO BIG MIKE.
AWESOME.
GOOD LUCK WITH THE WAGERS,
EVERYONE.
CONGRATS TO THE HOODIE AND
JERSEY WINNERS.
IF YOU WON, BR BETTING WILL
REACH OUT.
THANKS TO EVERYONE THAT
COMMENTED AND LEGENDS, W
W TRAMMEL.
TY, DO YOU WANT TO SAY GOOD-BYE
TO THE PEOPLE FOR US?
>> OH, YEAH.
HEY, GUYS, THANKS FOR TUNING IN.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
THE BETS HAVE FUN WITH IT.
DON'T GO TOO HARD.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME AND YO,
CHECK OUT THE NEW KID OUT THERE
ON THE BLOCK CLEAN DRINKING, V
1.
GOT TO GET YOU GUYS SOME.
GIVE ME A CALL.
I'LL SEND YOU A PACKAGE.
DOUBLE GOLD FIRST PLACE OFFICIAL
VODKA.
DON'T DRINK NOTHING ELSE BUT
THIS.
>> TY, I'LL TAKE YOU UP ON THAT
OFFER.
I ABSOLUTELY PROMISE.
I KNOW GREG WILL, TOO.
YOU HEARD OF V 1 VODKA ALONGSIDE
GREG AND TY, I'M CONNER ROGERS.
SEE YOU SAME TIME, SAME PLACE
NEXT WEEK.
ENJOY YOUR SUNDAY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
APPRECIATE IT, GUYS.